this is tomorrow reading for reviewer
heidi kemps as the first major original
jrpg on new consoles and the latest
installment of a very long running
series tales of arias comes with a lot
of expectations attached ari sets out to
refresh his visual presentation and
gameplay to appeal to a new audience by
also tries his best to retain what has
made the tale series so beloved among
long-time fans fun characters fast-paced
combat and an epic sense of scale while
it managed to succeed admirably at most
of what it tries to do a few
shortcomings keep it from being the new
standard bearer for rpgs to come
[Music]
300 years ago the planet of dhana was
invaded by the people of their
neighboring star reyna and crumbled
beneath the might of the reinan's
advanced technology and knowledge since
their conquest the reinans have
destroyed the once vibrant dharnan
culture and enslaved the planet's people
one day a nameless amnesiac slave known
only as iron mask finds himself caught
up in a supply train hijacking by rebel
forces and discovers that the freight is
a random woman with a strange curse as
he gets swept up in the dharnan
rebellion iron mask discovers new powers
his true name alfin and a connection to
the ren and girl xion but this tiny
slave rebellion grows into something
much bigger the beginning of tales of
arrias is a marked departure from the
chipper banter and adventuring most
hell's games lead off with with heavy
topics like slavery and oppression
taking center stage in the narrative the
overall tone of arizo's story for the
first several hours is quite downward
much as i hate to admit it there aren't
many of us who can take on those ren and
armored soldiers drilling into you the
sheer misery and desperation of the don
and people fortunately once your party
fills out the familiar tales party
dynamics come back in full force with
characters personalities bouncing off
each other in numerous entertaining
dialogue exchanges it's okay i won't
hurt you
[Music]
crap the rapport among your teammates
and watching their interactions change
as they go through individual character
arcs is a major draw and you'll find
yourself eager to keep playing just to
see the team react to the latest turn of
events around the campfire or complain
about the latest broken dungeon elevator
it's good that the characters are so
likable because they really help carry
the story through some rough patches the
abuse and liberation of oppressed
peoples is a very challenging and
prescient subject matter to tackle and
generally tales of arise handles the
material well but at times it
disappoints by not diving beyond the
superficial level into some of the
difficult moral issues the story
presents the pacing can also feel rushed
as the plot frequently introduces
characters who we don't get to know but
are suddenly rendered very important to
current events and then quickly exit the
narrative after contributing their main
story be while the narrative and arises
later half shifts thematically many of
the same issues remain throughout like
most jrpgs the narrative entails of a
rise is very linear that isn't a bad
thing however as the constant promise of
new lands to explore or new dungeons to
delve into is a strong impetus to keep
moving you're also presented with
numerous optional side quests to tackle
should you so choose to and a very
convenient fast travel system makes it
easy to return to previous areas should
you want to do additional exploration or
resource gathering for crafting and
cooking there's also a surprisingly
satisfying fishing mini game at ponzura
arise that if you're not careful will
consume far too much of your playtime
but as beautiful as arizer's
environments are the big gameplay draw
lies in battles the tail series has
always leaned heavily on the appeal of
its robust action-oriented combat and
arises no different in this respect
when you encounter enemies during
exploration you'll be spirited away off
to a combat screen where you go toe to
toe with foes in a small arena during
combat you can freely move and execute a
variety of normal and special attacks
called arts which you assign to
controller buttons naturally you can
also jump and guard
dodge enemy attacks heavy emphasis is
placed on positioning dodging and
chaining attacks together to land
massive combos breaking down foe's
resistance to set up team-based finishes
called a boost strike while you can only
directly control one character at a time
you can give your three companions
detailed strategies to follow and their
ai tends to function quite well there
are some interesting new twists to
combat this time around however
offensive and restorative arts no longer
use the same resource pool as healing
spells and environmental interactions
now utilize a separate party-wide cure
point stock this separation allows for
all characters to focus more heavily on
offense during battle and there's no
need to worry about saving a specific
character's arts for healing in
emergencies though some characters like
shion will still need to be ready to
switch between fighting and healing when
needed and the cure points paul always
needs to be carefully monitored each
character is also given unique perks
that differentiate themselves and
establish their particular roles in
battle making each of them play wildly
differently from each other alfin can
sacrifice hp after using art to deal
extra damage sprightly mage rinwell can
charge and hold her magical arts to
chain together combos more easily
elegant knight kisara guards with her
massive shield rather than dodging and
performs enhanced arts out of her
guarding stance and so on each character
also has a unique limited use boost
attack that serves a distinct purpose
like law's armor shattering punches or
dohalim's movement restricting vines
many of these layers to combat aren't
revealed or aren't obvious right away
instead being rolled out over the course
of the game a good chunk of each
character's skills will need to be
opened up as you play through the skill
panel system where you spend sp earned
throughout their game to enhance your
character's abilities in combat there's
always something fresh and new being
added to the combat as a result making
tales of orisa's battles feel
consistently fresh when tales of arises
combat is at its best it feels like a
well-oiled machine with arts flying
enemies being smacked around and juggled
through the air armor being crushed and
guards being broken all topped off by a
spectacular finishing boot strike or
mystic art to crush foes into oblivion
but it's not always that smooth and
satisfying sometimes there's just so
much happening on screen at once with
much of it out of your control that it's
difficult to keep track of what arts
your squad is tossing at the enemy and
what attacks they're flinging back at
you particularly during boss fights or
when you're taking on a large enemy pack
it's not uncommon to find yourself
severely damaged or ko'd without fully
understanding why and while it's fairly
easy to pick yourself back up it's still
frustrating there were numerous times
when i felt like i was playing at my
best and still getting pummeled for
reasons that were unclear unlike many
other tales games arise doesn't offer
any co-op play so you can't rely on a
buddy to help keep things under control
either and then there's the dlc problem
while tales of auris offers some paid
cosmetic dlc extra costumes and
decorations which don't change gameplay
it also offers gameplay boosting
packages that grant bonuses like
permanent exp and sp boosts massive shop
discounts reducing all crafting and
cooking materials needed to one and so
on while this is an optional purchase
the fact that exists at all constantly
made me second guess the game's design
decisions are healing items expensive to
teach me to take less damage or to get
me to buy a shop discount dlc package
are boss fights so much harder than
standard fights because the designers
really want to test my skills or because
i didn't get that exp boost dlc i often
felt like money and resources like sp
were being kept scarce so instead of
focusing completely on having fun and
exploring tales of verizon's various
gameplay systems i was often wondering
if i was being subtly pushed to buy
gameplay advantages
taken as a whole tales of arias is a
very good rpg boasting beautiful visuals
a wonderful cast of characters and
engaging combat mechanics but his flaws
and their odious dlc are also difficult
to ignore
if you're looking for a lengthy charming
and engaging jrpg to play on your shiny
new console or pc gaming rig tails of a
rise is certainly a fine choice just
don't go into expecting an all-time
classic
[Music]
unsullied fertile land as far as the eye
can see
that's beautiful
[Applause]
what
no nothing just
i was thinking the very same thing